[Music]
hope you have been having a great day so
far and hope you're enjoying all the
next sessions that we have organized for
you my name is pranav Nar I'm a director
of product management on Google cloud
and I would like to welcome all of you
to this session on digital
transformation with Google's
databases in this session I'm also
joined by two Tech leaders from the
industry we have sudhir Kumar Redi who
is a senior principal architect at flip
cart one of India's largest e-commerce
companies we also have yein Chopra who
is a senior manager at Deo one of gcps
top
Partners so between the three of us
we're going to bring in three different
perspectiv Ives to this session I'm
going to talk about the product and
business side of things sudhir is going
to talk about it from the customer side
and Yin is going to talk about it from
the partner side and I'm hoping that
between these three perspectives you'll
have a very insightful session hopefully
you'll get new Inspirations new ideas as
you think about digital
transformation so without further Ado
let's get going as I said we would like
to organize the session into three parts
I'll start off with the discussion on
digital transformation and also give you
a peek into some of our top innovations
that we have announced at
next uh we will then have sudhir who's
going to talk about flip cart's digital
transformation journey and then Yin is
going to talk about their partnership
with Kroger and what they did around
associate productivity with digital
transformation okay so without further
delay let's Dive Right In into the first
section on digital
transformation I wanted to start off
with a very thought-provoking question
which I'm sure all of us have asked at
some time or the other and the question
is are you set up for
Innovation let's face it in today's
world digital innovators are disrupting
the traditional players the bar on
customer experience is Raising every day
in fact with Technologies like gen it's
going to expand even further and for
every company to stay relevant in
inovation is key and to drive Innovation
you need a foundation of good technology
and good
architecture which is where digital
transformation becomes so
important so in fact according to
IDC in
2025 about $2.8 trillion is going to be
invested globally by companies on
digital transformation that kind of
shows the importance companies are
giving to digital transformation in fact
let me show you another interesting stat
here's a Google Trends report on digital
transformation and as you can see it's
be see been seeing a you know bit of a
spike in the past couple of years as
reference point if you compare it with
the big data wave that started in
2010 you can clearly see that there's a
new wave now with the digital
transformation also with Technologies
like gen data cloud and pieces like that
a few of which I'll touch upon we
believe this new wave of digital
transformation is going to be much
bigger than the Big Data wave that we
have seen so
far so what's the big deal about digital
transformation frankly digital
transformation is around all around
transformation for your
company you can no longer be
unidimensional as a company in this
world you'll have to not only look at
Cost reduction productivity Improvement
uh you know C customer retention scale
reliability trust sustainability you'll
have to look at all these Dimensions
together and that's where your
technology Investments are going to be
extremely
critical in fact none of these
challenges that you see here on the
slide here are anything new I'm sure all
companies have been dealing with day in
and day out for years but the difference
right now is it's looking at all around
transformation but there's one unique
factor and that factor is you need to
Future proof your applications for
digital
transformation let me give you a simple
example let's say you're a gaming
company youve built a game you think
it's going to be a good game you have
actually set it up such that it can
scale to tens of thousands of
users but what if you were an overnight
success and you actually saw hundreds of
thousands if not millions of users what
if your technology could not scale to
deliver a good user experience
do you think you'll be able to retain
this user base again do you think you'll
be able to win back this lost
opportunity it's less likely in this
world because the bar and the
expectation that customers have is
evolving and it's a very high bar these
days so that's where future proofing is
so important and when you talk about
your technology stack the most core
component of the stack is your data
management clear that's because data is
where you insights lie data is where you
can innovate data is where you have the
pieces that can help you build better
experiences so the big question we
should ask is how should we future proof
our data management layer or our
databases per
se let me give you another example I'm
sure all of you use digital banking
these days you know you have your mobile
app you try to use banking transactions
on the app how would you feel if you get
the dreaded message we are undergoing
maintenance right now sorry please try
again later
I'm pretty sure you would not want to
use the app again you might start
thinking about other options that you
want to exercise that's the world we
live in the nature of applications have
changed the expectations have changed so
you need a database layer that can
actually scale to your requirements that
can be always on you know there's no
concept of Maintenance downtime anymore
I know companies today they try to find
you know low traffic durations weekends
Etc to do some level of Maintenance but
if people face a downtime something
critical is going to happen they're
going to lose trust you also need your
data management layer to actually be
extremely elastic so it can deal with
ups and downs in your traffic you need
to be price performant secure and
compliant now all these challenges all
these aspects easier said than done it's
difficult to get all these together and
that's the same challenge Google faced
in fact all through Google's Evolution
Google had to rethink data management we
had to reinvent the concept of databases
as such today we have three different
Services which kind of power almost all
of Google's applications and these
applications cater to billions of users
worldwide so what are these
Services first and foremost we have big
table which is our key value database
which is extremely suited for large
scale low latency High throughput
applications it's useful for iot it's
useful for ad click tracking it's even
useful as a feature store for your aim
applications the next one is spanner
which is kind of a hybrid between
relational and non-relational databases
spanner offers you the adet capabilities
the SQL capabilities of a relational
database it also offers you the scale
and reliability of a non-relational
database so you get the mix of both and
so spanner offers you a very versatile
experience and it's useful for a number
of use cases including Financial
transactions inventory management gaming
and so on the next one is fire store
which is our serverless document
database built on top of spanner so fire
store not only gives you all the goodies
that spanner offers it also offers you
backend as a service so with fir store
you no longer need to deal with middle
tiers you can directly invoke the
database from your clients in fact fir
store also gives you offline online
modes it gives you realtime sync
capabilities across clients making it
extremely suited for mobile and web kind
of
scenarios but internally all these
applications power you the Google
applications are powered by these
services and so we're continuously
trying to innovate we're trying to
innovate by repeatedly raising the table
Stakes so these services offer you five
nines of availability which is industry
leading there's no concept of
Maintenance downtime so you don't have
to bother finding low traffic situations
or weekends for these Services Google
takes care of it for you you don't have
to even bother about it these services
offer you really high levels of uh uh
availability they also offer you really
high levels of fall tolerance it also
offers you automatic partitioning so by
that way you can actually you don't have
to handle manual partitioning and
sharding of your data because it takes
care of the scale for you pretty much as
you need pretty much unlimited scale is
available for you in addition to that
there's a good experience around Global
replication it's not something new for
databases but when you actually enter
false scenarios how do you recover how
do you fail over it's a fully fully
manage experience for you Google takes
care of those complexities for you last
but not the least it also offers you
great price performance and security and
compliance so if you haven't already
this these are some services that you
would want to check out uh and we are
continuously investing and innovating in
these Services all through and with that
let me switch over to actually talk
about some of our latest
Innovations the lot of features that we'
have announced at next for some of these
but I'm going to touch upon two key
themes data cloud andl and I'm going to
handpick just a few of these Innovations
which I think are going to be very
impactful for digital
transformation let's start with the
first one I'm really excited to share
with you that we are announcing the
availability of cloud spanner data boost
in GA right now data boost is our
transformative technology that actually
enables you to run analytics on your
operational workloads with hardly any
impact on your transactional
applications so how does it actually
work as you might know all our database
services that I just mentioned here have
a segregated compute and storage
architecture so storage actually sets on
a distributed service called Colossus in
fact Colossus is the same service that
powers big query and
GCS so when you provision spanner
resources and when you make a query
spanner actually processes the queries
and then interfaces with Colossus to
actually process your data with data
boost you get a parallel isolated
Channel which scales on demand and can
directly process the data in Colossus
without affecting your spanner
instances so you might be wondering okay
that's great you know it gives you great
levels of isolation maybe it's a unique
design but so what well what if I told
you data boost is your key to truly
enabling data sharing in your
organization
it's your key to actually get data
democratization in your organization let
me explain in the traditional world you
have a bunch of teams each having their
own databases I'm sure all of you are
dealing with that what if you have a
team of analysts who want to access that
data and derive insights from that data
so to get access to it and actually
figure out how they can utilize the data
they have to get into this negotiation
and contract building with the database
owner the database owner has to figure
out how much to scale how how can you
build in isolations how can you have
enough throttling mechanisms so the
business critical workloads are not
impacted with your analyst making some
massive queries to your database now
just think if every team has to make
these negotiations with each other to
access the data then how combersome
would it be this is not a future proof
world this is actually taking you back
so data boost changes his equation
completely so with datab Boost as a
database owner you are just enabling
access to spanner for let's say a
specific role like say an analyst role
and giving them access VI are data boost
so if you have analysts who wants to
query spanner they can just come over
and make their queries they pay for the
capacity that they use datab boost will
automatically scale as much as needed
and then it's going to query and
interface with Colossus get the data
without affecting your transactional
workloads so this is the era of true
data democratization a world where data
sharing becomes extreme seamless as I
told you earlier data is where the
insights lie and data is how you can
innovate so this is going to be very
crucial but I'm not done yet data boost
can also enable you up to 100x more
performant queries for specific queries
because you have got a dedicated Fleet
that's actually provisioned on the fly
to handle those queries it can even help
you with cost reduction because you're
not duplicating your data you're not
having to over provision for some of
these analytical queries and other
access patterns it also simplifies
governance because in the end you have
just one copy of your
data okay so with that let me touch upon
the other piece so fine you know data
boost is a great mechanism for you to
query the data spark big query whatever
scenarios that you have but what if you
really need to replicate the data that's
where we have chain
streams spanner big table and fire store
all integrate ability to realtime stream
changes to Downstream systems like big
query so essentially we have a bunch of
inbuilt connectors which makes this very
easy for you in fact you could go one
step further and you could even build
event driven programming by listening
for specific changes in your uh uh you
know database updates and then taking
actions
accordingly so now chain streams and
data boost both enable you to consume
content from the
databases what if you had to do it in a
reverse
Direction that's where reverse ETL comes
in I'm really excited to share with you
that we've got two mechanisms here on
firestore we have fir store extensions
that helps you schedule jobs which can
materialize data from Big query to
firestore and on big table we are now
announcing in preview ability to export
data from Big query to big table so no
longer do you need any ETL pipelines for
this you can pretty much just with a few
clicks get get the data exported to big
table and as you all know data
warehouses are not best at serving
traffic you need reliable High scale low
latency databases to accomplish that and
that's what reverse ETL capabilities
here will do so it's essentially like
the world where you had wires and you
had to connect everything and now it's
kind of a plug-in play world where you
can just click a few buttons and it'll
take care of things for you so and trust
me we're just getting started here we're
going to expand on many of these data
boost is Al going to come over to big
table and other services it's all going
to expand to all the other services that
we
have with that let me switch over to the
other uh pattern which is
AIML I'm happy to share with you that we
now have spanner integration with WX aai
uh in GA so this actually provides you
realtime intelligence capabilities so
you could essentially invoke a model for
predictions in real time in the context
of your transaction so if you're doing a
credit card transaction you can validate
if it's a fraud and in the SQL context
itself you could block it or you could
actually continue with it in fact we are
also further going to extend this to
llms large language models so you can
actually build your generative AI
applications with spanner and interface
with llms u you know and get the results
VI within the spanner context itself so
that's coming
shortly I'm not done yet so I'm really
happy to share with you that we are also
announcing spanner studio in preview
spanner studio is like a One-Stop shop
to query visualize and anal you know
evaluate the data that you have in
spanner what's more with dit AI in
spanner we are actually enabling you to
generate SQL statements with just simple
comments this is really cool uh you know
I didn't have the time for a demo but
generally you should go and try it out
you can just provide a comment for it to
create a table for specific entities
it'll even create the SE for you it can
even add data into your tables if you
want to test things out or have some
sample data added it'll create the SQL
for you you know right away just by
simple comments and it'll take care of
it for you so we believe this going to
drastically improve the efficiency for
uh you know all the developers here and
again we're just getting started there's
a lot more coming down the lane so
you'll see this going further and
further and hopefully this going to
transform things even
further well I'm not done yet so I'm
really excited to also share with you
that we have got a bunch of AIML
extensions for fir store available for
you we've got extensions for text
enrichment like checking text toxicity
or text summarization we got extensions
for IM uh you know media enrichment like
image comparison for similarity or
speech to text conversions we also have
extensions for interactive AI like
chatbots so you could actually build
chatbots or chat applications with e
with the power of Vex Ai and Fir store
combined so I can keep going the the
more announcements here but in the
interest of time I'm going to stop here
uh let me hand over the stage to sudhir
he's going to talk to you about Flipkart
and its journey in the digital
transformation space over to you
sudhir thanks
brov hello everyone it's a pleasure to
be here uh I'm happy to share with you
Flipkart uh how we have modernized the
data platform architecture on top of gcp
and we'll talk about how a real-time
platform is helping us solve some of the
key business decisions to be made
instantly Flipkart is the largest
e-commerce company in India Walmart is
one of our largest investor in the last
16 years flipcart has increased adoption
of e-commerce in India today we have
more than onethird of Indians shopping
online on us if you imagine the
population of entire Los Angeles that is
the number of firsttime users who were
on flip card last year for few days of
sale right on the largest sale that we
have is Big billion Day Sale which is
equivalent to your Black Friday sale
which we have here um in the last sale
the first minute or first few second the
first second of the sale the entire
population of San Francisco and sanos
combined were trying to enter flip card
the same time that's the scale that we
talking about and what does it take to
run the infrastructure at this scale we
have millions of CES we hundreds of gpus
we have exabytes of storage and we have
hundreds of gbps of internet connection
to solve the needs right and how do we
run this we are in a hybrid mode we have
two of our private data centers which we
run on Prem with with our own team and
then we have two of our uh regions
running on gcp in India regions and the
reason we have chosen this is e-commerce
being a bursty business where we have a
lot of peak traffic at times it makes
sense for us to work with Google public
cloud provider to use on demand
infrastructure and it has helped us a
lot our data platform is primar located
on Google
Cloud so the scale of the data platform
if you see we have more than 2,500 feeds
of different types of events which we
capture from the application with mobile
application as well as the services
which run on Flipkart and all of them
inj just close to 700 terabytes of data
in a day right and we have more than 130
billion messages that we inest in a day
if you look at the overall size of the
data platform we have 80 plus pedabytes
of storage and we process on a daily
basis 15 plus pedabytes of data across
multiple 8,000 odd pipelines right and
uh the volume of this is equivalent to 4
billion close to 4 billion photos high
definition photos being processed in a
day right coming to the real-time
platform uh we have 900 plus
applications running in uh on on the
services and we they process more than 2
petabytes a day
and we have more than a million messages
being processed per second
right so what does the platform look
like right this is a very simplified
version of the platform uh so if you see
at at a primary uh bottom layer we have
the injection layer we have inje where
some of the systems ingest in batch mode
where they are not able to do it and
most of the systems ingest in realtime
mode within few seconds of the
activities on end user devices or the
services servers which run all of that
data gets into the data platform from
there it enters to a messaging queue and
from there the real-time platform
consumes it and serves critical business
use cases for end users which are
business users or developers or analysts
who wants to look at the data or they
even get into the serving systems for uh
optimizations CTR predictions and other
systems are there right and then there's
a whole uh data which comes in we store
it as it is uh for batch consumption
then we have close to 9,000 odd
pipelines which run different types of
workloads on top of it right one spark
map reduce and other workloads to do
different type of analytics on top of it
and serve that to different systems via
reports or adog query
analysis or even export to their own
systems right oh sorry just to add to
that we also have data quality uh on
this in the platform we have metadata
and then we have Knowledge Graph these
are all some things which have invested
on Prem over
time so on Prem we were running
primarily on the Hadoop text track we
had Hadoop hdfs Yan uh Edge Bas vertica
Kafka and all of these elastic sege Tex
tracks when we looked at modernizing it
with gcp we picked some of the best
offerings from them we've looked at pups
up big table data
proc uh GCS all of these and we found
that doing the right mix of what we have
invested over time versus is what Google
has invested over time what is the best
combination of it to leverage for us
purpose and we have picked it up in a
mode that uh we can run the data
platform at scale for handling big blend
day sale right and we had given the size
of the data we have 80 pedabytes of data
we were we did a migration in 6 months
the entire data onto gcp and were able
to run all of the 10,000 odd
pipelines as on gcp and without having a
downtime we did a seamless migration
within a very short time of 6 months
and all of it was able to be achieved
because of the kind of uh stable systems
that we have on Google cloud and the
Investments that we have done at our
end right coming to realtime systems
right uh what are the use cases that we
have today in the in in in our company
right so the moment user is active on
the app flip cart app within single
digit seconds we get the entire funnel
right from how many unique visits are
happening right now on flip cart to to
how many users are actually browsing the
product po Pages which category of pages
are they browsing to how many products
are being checked out to the entire
orders being placed the entire funnel of
it we today computed in single digit
seconds of the activity on the user
device right lot of use cases on CDR
predictions for the search to optimize
the algorithms for better ranking uh
there are use cases where the
advertising systems take it for
improving what which ads are more uh
more likely to be clicked on right so
there are lot of these fraud detection
use cases a lot of uh Finance wants a
view of saying how is the business doing
right now they want to understand how
what categories are working well what is
not working well uh what is the profit
and loss for each of these verticals a
lot of these use cases which they want
data in near real time and all of these
are being powered by our
platform so over the years we have
invested in a platform internally called
as fstream uh this is equivalent to the
Google beam if you're aware uh this is
an abstraction built layer um underneath
we have Apache spark and Flink uh and we
have built abstractions specifically for
our business use cases where uh there is
repeated code which most of the
pipelines have it we try to abstract it
out in a easier way so the developer Li
writes less number of codes for his
purpose um so most of the stuff like uh
we do is there are multiple pipelines
like there's a order Pipeline and
there's a cancellation Pipeline and
there is a category pipelines which come
in right most of these are different
systems in the company and then how do
you combine all of that into a single
metric that people are interested in and
that to near real time right so we have
invested in scaling these systems
building these abstractions over the
years um and the key requirements for
these are highly durable reliable and uh
scalable right so this is the key USB
that we have built over years and how
does the system look like if you look at
high level design it basically this is a
very simplified version of it so if you
see there are users doing
activities and there is a web service
which captures all of that data and
inest into uh the pubsub and from pubsub
we consume it by our pipelines and then
we Pump It data into big query and big
table and then we have reports on top of
big query this is very simplified
version of it underneath I'll give you
an example of a use case today if you
were to compute uh how what is a CD
prediction for the pipelines right for
search so you will have search views
coming in VI one pipeline you will have
search clicks coming in VI another
pipeline you'll have the category of the
product like which category what is a a
metadata Associated to the category
coming in from other product so all of
those are handled by the F steam layer
with just declarative code for the
application developers or a SQL code and
all of this computes in near real time
and pushes it into these stores on Prem
we were primarily running this on Kafka
this layer
and our own Edge Bas setup clusters over
here and we had elastic search and
vertica here when we mve to gcp we
modernized this by replacing it with
pubsub big table and big query and
looker so what are the benefits
associated with this right big table is
amazingly scalable right we today run
big table cluster with 1400 plus nodes
uh today the kind of operations we do is
equivalent to reading a 4K HD movie with
every second that's the kind of scale we
use H table uh big table
for right so it's it's it's actually
working out really well for us right
Edge Bas had a lot of issues operational
issues for us a lot of hours used to be
spent by the developers in ensuring the
stability of the system in fixing
day-to-day issues and they were not
focusing on the platform capabilities or
the data products on top of it so by
moving to big table all of that Ops over
it has gone away for us it's become very
easy for us right and it has led to
fewer incidents fewer outages and uh
approximately 10% of the up down times
which were caused previously with Edge
base and other self-managed TCH stacks
and all have gone right Edge table uh
big big table is cost effective for us
right it has an amazing order scale
functionality right now for big billion
day kind of sale we have huge amount of
users which coming in but not in a baau
in in in a regular day right so how do
you handle that kind of scale so big
table all we have to do is have a and
Max configured and the systems
automatically scale up and scale down
right and help us save the cost so we've
seen upwards of 20% cost reduction in
some of these pipelines right and and uh
given the size of scale we need required
for big billion Day Sale we have seen it
working really nice without having any
issues and it's been really well for us
right and the most interesting thing for
us was the open source compatibility
because we previously running on edge
Bas and Edge Bas a compatible API works
as it is on to a big table we didn't
have to do do any code changes all of
more 9 900 odd pipelines seamlessly run
on this so overall it's very easy for us
to migrate and set up and run it on
Google
cloud and this gives you out of the box
business continuity plan where you can
set it up in multiple regions given the
kind of requirements we have our our
business users want to look right now
what is happening during a big billion
day kind of a sale right so we can't
afford a single minute of downtime of
the Pipelines so at these kind of sales
we run it in two of the regions in
parallel big table replication happens
out of the box pubs up replication
happens out of the box we have pipelines
deployed in both the regions to compute
and we have reporting dashboarding
Solutions where we built a BCB lot of
these Solutions were very simplified by
using this plug- and play building
blocks and we were focusing more on the
high level abstraction and uh products
on top of the core infrastructure which
was provided out of the box for
us right overall I would say big table
has been a big powerful tool for us in
scaling up our systems and helping us
run the sale at where we are today and
we are hoping this year it'll be larger
than the last year sale and hoping that
things go smooth right so this I'll hand
over to
uh he'll continue on this thank you all
I hope this was
[Applause]
useful hello hello okay thanks sudir uh
good afternoon everybody uh my name is
yatin Chopra I'm part of deo's AI and
data practice and I spent most of my
career serving retailers um helping them
maximize value out of the data assets by
Building Solutions which generate
insights and insights which
Drive operational excellence by
improving associate experience which is
what we'll talk about here in a second
and then also insights which actually
help in customer retention as well as
acquisition
um deoy and and and gcp have had a very
strong and growing relationship uh just
yesterday uh we were recognized for
partner of the year in 2023 for four
different categories um and we are
showing up as one team uh across
multiple strategic
accounts as a backdrop the last 10 years
or so has been spent uh really
digitizing or improving the consumer
experience
um it was not until I would say uh as
the pandemic began that you know there
was a a light shed on what about the
associate so for for retailers who have
large physical store presence right they
and facing you know Talent shortages and
other things what would and the lack of
uh digitization it was pretty uh I would
say slammed on opportunity to start
automating and digitizing the day-to-day
working of an associate because a great
associate experience directly influences
an amazing consumer
experience with that
said Kroger as a retailer um expansive
physical presence uh more than 2800
stores uh fun fact I found out earlier I
think last week um they were the
largest Sushi seller in 2022 uh who
would have known 40 million pieces of
sushi sold
um but you know the challenges here was
they have more than 400,000 Associates
and actually they have made I would say
in The Last 5 Years very strategic bets
on improving the associate experience
and one such was called associate
productivity which is what I'll talk
about
next what we built here on cloud I mean
obviously uh gcp uh Native Google and
and deloid showed up as one uh we built
a smart data platform which which Powers
two applications application one which
is the tasking application which is you
know it pushes um in in the consumer
speak we say next best offer but think
of next best action for an associate to
do so imagine the power of having um
data and insights on in your in your
hand and I actually have
U uh the app in my mobile phone so I can
demo it later uh at our booth at deoe
but pushes what we should be doing next
based on events happening in the store
and then the second application was
store audit which is just making sure
that you know what was previously only
registered on paper has been digitized
to make sure that all the processes are
happening uh as they were planned for or
standing operating
procedures like any good consulting firm
uh you know we have a framework of
selecting databases so when we started
putting pieces together uh to build the
architecture this is now summer of
2021 um we you know we actually started
uh to prove out the hypothesis that if
we actually empowered and associate with
what they should be doing next that we
can actually move the needle and make
them more productive in their day-to-day
jobs so we started actually with
postgress or Cloud SQL and we started
with three stores with the PC went well
over a 10e period um and then using the
same architecture we moved up to 25
stores it wasn't actually until when we
hit 100 stores and the data we were
flowing in that we realized we were
going to start missing very specific SLA
is required and also the experience the
associat was having it's it's then is
when we decided that you know uh we move
over and parallel track to spanner uh
which delivered a fit across the board
and as U PR of also pointed out right um
I think the key here was um we I would
you know we delayed scaling past 100
Stores um as we caught up and re
architected and putting spanner as the
backbone of our architecture and then um
you know 500 stores at a time is when we
have scaled and we've been now live at
more than 2400 stores for the last year
uh bolted on many more capabilities and
use cases and tasks and things are going
well um quick look at the deployment
architecture you know we are ingesting
data from on Prem multiple sources
whether as HR Trucking logic whatever
signals are happening in the store um
they all are stitched together and
stored in the spard database and each
application underlying store is also a
spanner um the data science layer which
is where the magic happens in terms of
priorization and task creation that's
what pushes out to the mobile phones and
then as Associates are actually using um
and and doing their day-to-day jobs that
feedback is loop back in and those
events then trigger the next set of
actions what we are today um over the
last 18 months we've built a central
tasking application
um and we have just recently over the
summer also so today what we've done so
far was be able to prioritize and um do
the next best action for associates
within a department but then what
happens if you have excess labor on
another department and not enough work
to do on the other one where we've been
able to prove the hypothesis that if I
needed help in Bakery and there was
actually more tasks to be done and
somebody didn't show up but there was
another associate with train and the
skills available in a different
Department how do I guide that associate
to do that task so we call it directed
uh work for that also has Improvement
which will be put into place you know
later this year um again the Mantra
being right associate right task at the
right
time um with this client a lot of paper
based processes now have been digitized
so we've collected a lot of data over
the last year which are now going to
help us do more labor recommendations
scheduling recommendations and even
Dynamic walks and tasking which is
basically helping them put potentially
you know pivot away from processes
they've been following uh within the
store for retail Ops over the last 10 or
15 years and then finally the vision
obviously in the next couple years is uh
fully connected store and this is a very
complimentary platform in the
system with that as I hand it over back
over to perov I would say that you know
we showed up as one team which is
whether it's deloid Kroger um and Google
um obviously spanner um was critical to
the success and the scale we needed to
achieve and we're extremely excited
about how we unpack we have a road map
of capabilities going in fy4 where we
will be unpacking um data boost is what
pram had said and then vertex AI so
putting in the data science of the AI
models in
play FR of I'll hand it back over to
you thank you yatan so thank you yatan
and Sadir for sharing some really
valuable insights
uh I hope this was very useful for you
definitely we try to capture different
perspectives uh in the end there are few
patterns that you might see emerging
from all these three different flavors
of discussions one is around how data is
being handled there's a t now there's a
focus around bringing data together
breaking down the silos so you can have
better insights sudhir talked about
realtime insights because that's where
the differentiation is if you remember
earlier when I started I asked with the
question are you all set for Innovation
that's the place where you could
actually make a difference by actually
going more real time versus something
that's postevent right in this world in
the end it boils down to the kind of
technology that you can pick up on I
gave you a brief overview a very high
level overview of some of these
technology pieces that we have been
investing in some of the announcements
that we shared but if you are interested
we definitely have some dedicated
session
specific deep dive sessions that will
actually go deeper into many of these
topics whether it's spanner big table
fire store some of our geni pieces
please check them out that'll be very
informative for all of you is what I
believe and last but not the least
please do take the time to provide us
feedback I know digital transformation
is not an easy Journey I've had a lot of
conversations with industry leaders and
customers a number of challenges in
there Google has gone through the same
process and so you know some of our
services we built was just to help us
with that journey I look at digital
transformation more as a journey as than
as a destination so you know think of it
as continuous Evolution think of it as
something that you need to continuously
future proof yourself for because new
unpredictable things will come down the
lane hopefully you know some of these
pieces that we shared has triggered some
level of ideas or Inspirations in your
minds hopefully this was useful to you
with that I wish you the very best in
your digital transformation Journey
thank you so much we will be around here
for questions if you want you can come
over I think we're almost at time so you
can come over to us and you know we can
answer your questions uh if you want to
check out some of our services there's
definitely boots there you know as de uh
you know yet mentions some the he can
show you the app there as well also you
know if you have account teams with you
reach out to them if you want to do a
deep dive with any of these Services
we'll be more than happy to help you out
with that thank you so much you've been
a great audience wish you all the
[Music]
best